just a reminder now of what's in the law
and why it's caused such widespread
opposition so it creates a pathway to
citizenship to minorities who face
religious persecution in Pakistan
Bangladesh and Afghanistan but it
excludes Muslims opposition parties on
protesters say it violates India's
secular Constitution but that's not the
only dynamic playing out in states
bordering Bangladesh West Bengal is
controlled by an opposition party the
ruling BJP is being accused of seeking
electoral gains for the regional vote
due in 2021 by opening the door to more
Hindu refugees and migrants while in
nearby northeastern states especially
Assam indigenous people fear an influx
of hindu bengalis they say that could
put their language and culture under
threat let speak to Tarun chitin he's a
professor of law and legal theory at the
University of Oxford he's also the
general editor of Indian Law Review he's
joining us from London thanks very much
for being with us on the al Jazeera news
hour so interestingly our reporter from
New Delhi was just saying that the
students who are protesting right now in
front of the universities are discussing
the importance of upholding the Indian
Constitution yet you say that the
government is using unconstitutional
means to curb freedom of expression what
do you mean by that so look this
government has been chipping away at
India's constitutional fundamentals for
the last six years but this act does it
so blatantly and so expressly that
there's no plausible deniability Indian
institutions constitutional institutions
have failed just to stop the government
from doing what it has done to the
Constitution and ultimately it seems of
the people have decided that it's upon
them to save India's pluralistic secular
democratic constitution so it's it's
really amazing to see how the
Constitution's preamble has become the
symbol of these protests you know these
are not being organized by a political
party there is no social movement or NGO
behind them
and you know the preamble being read out
publicly collectively in almost every
protest that has been happening around
this act is is really astonishing of
course the state's response has been
remarkably disproportionate and and
blatantly unconstitutional so clamp
downs on freedom of speech Internet is
being suspended you know in turn is
being suspended in Kashmir for the last
four months but but in places where
protests happen you know it's hard to
organize these protests without social
media so governments have been shutting
down mobile internet connections
telephone lines advisories to
universities asking them to monitor
students social media posts the police
has been imposing what's called section
144 of the Criminal Procedure Code which
basically makes it illegal for any
crowds to assemble which again without
although it's permitted in law it has to
be for very good reason for protecting
law and order situation that's what I
wanted to ask you about specifically in
fact section 144 because in the
Constitution it does authorize officials
to prohibit among other things a
gathering as you're saying of more than
four people if they fear a possible
violation of law and order so so you're
saying that the the government is not
acting within the Constitution when it
implements that section 144 so section
144 is not a constitutional provision it
is a provision in the Criminal Procedure
Code which which is a legacy of the
colonial administration to India what
the Constitution protects is the freedom
of assembly and the freedom of the
citizens assembly can only be restricted
on certain reasonable grounds and only
proportionately so yes the government
has the power under form 144 to clamp
down on assembly but it can do so only
for very good reasons and it has to
follow proper procedures and in a
substantive reason so so it cannot for
example what the government cannot do is
use 144 to stop the expression of
citizens dissent or a citizen any
citizens group that wants to do
advocate for a change in policy or show
it's disaffection for any government
governmental policy that is not
permissible by the Indian Constitution
and that is what the government is doing
why is the citizenship law that's caused
all these protests seen by many people
as a threat to Indian democracy as a
whole so there been a lot of threats
during a democracy of late but this is
the most blatant because for the first
time in India's democratic independent
history we are going to write religion
as a qualification into our citizenship
laws the law in giving fast-track
citizenship to basically non-muslims but
also some other residues ATS Muslims
some of these communities are not
covered but Hindus Sikhs and Jews are
covered that is that is just so
blatantly against the very core of the
Indian Constitution identity which is to
seek to to build a nation that is not
based on religious identity that is
secular that is pluralistic that is
diverse and it's celebrated that
diversity for the last 70 odd years so
that it's it's the explicitness you know
a lot of these government's policies
have been sort of dog-whistle politics
of everybody knows the code is
anti-muslim but now the government felt
emboldened to do not feel the need for
force for dog whistles it's just do you
think it's a government has been caught
off guard by the size of these protests
and the ongoing protests and and how do
you see this playing playing out going
forward is there any way that the
government will go back on this decision
in this law it's not just a government
that has been caught off guard
it's the protests of Survivor have
surprised everyone including people like
me you know academics have been watching
Indian politics and constitution for a
long time nobody expected this because
things were relatively quiet over the
Ayodhya judgement over the lynchings
that have been happening in India for
the last few years so so why why now and
why so suddenly why on this issue is
it's a little bit surprising and I think
people are thinking about what what
triggered it I think that is
proportionate use of violence against do
in jamia including students who were not
in protesting but studying in libraries
police beating them up the videos that
circulated I think they they were the
catalysts and there's also a building up
of of disgruntlement against the
government that has just poured out on
the streets not just by Muslims you know
people from all communities have have
joined this protest the government has
been caught off guard I don't know
whether they have the reflexively you
know the flexibility and the
responsiveness to to react to the
protests but what is needed is they have
to repeal this law I think I think
Parliament needs to be recalled
immediately the amendments have to be
repealed but a lot older laura's has to
be done because what this government's
intentions in relation to its Muslim
population to India's Muslim population
is is deeply under suspicion and the
country has to prove its good faith now
by passing an anti-discrimination law
and a host of other things
Khaitan we thank you very much for
joining us from London